right burden was directed by david
yarrow VES key and stars Elizabeth Banks
and David Denman and tells the story of
a young boy that crashed lands on a farm
and the couple that runs the farm was
trying to have a child and they weren't
able to and so when this baby lands on
their farm in a spaceship they decide
this is perfect and they raise the kid
as their own but as the kid gets older
he begins to display powers and
abilities that at first are fascinating
but quickly turned to evil the script is
written by Brian and Mark Gunn and
produced by James Gunn so clearly these
guys know each other
and they got together in they made a
movie and that's awesome because this
movie has a unique twist to it if I were
pitching this movie to a studio like if
I wrote it I would say it's Chronicle
meets Superman it's evil Superman
give me monies because Studios love
their comps they want to know what's
been made that resembles what you want
to make meaning that you can't actually
make anything original so that's that
it's you know the review so basically
the movie is saying what if everything
in the Superman comic happened except
instead of becoming a force for justice
and good this kids like yeah now I'm
gonna murder you which is a good idea
that mostly pays off in a really tight
and compact horror movie it's pretty
bloody - I was impressed with some of
the kills in the movie that took me
off-guard I didn't really know what the
movie was rated going in I wasn't sure
if it was pg-13 or R definitely an
r-rated movie and there's a scene where
it for sure becomes rated R and you're
like yep that's good you went for it you
didn't back off good job one of the
reasons this movie really worked for me
were the two main performances of the
parents played by Elizabeth Banks and
David Denman they had excellent
chemistry together I completely bought
their relationship they felt like they
had been through a lot there was so much
that they gave to the role that wasn't
necessarily even on the page just these
subtle nuances between the two and
Elizabeth Banks as this woman who just
desperately wanted to be a mother but
wasn't able to and had this amazing
opportunity you can feel the the
desperation and the struggle and
everything that she does in some movies
where you see a parent that's very
oblivious
- how terrible their child is you start
to feel kind of annoyed with the parent
like come on but as someone who worked
for a school system for a couple years
way before I ever started doing this I
can tell you the majority of parents
never believe their children do anything
wrong
there they have a really hard time
accepting that it's very true but in
this movie certain things are presented
- Elizabeth Banks character like Hello
like your kids obviously got issues and
instead of being annoyed with the fact
that she doesn't want to accept it I
felt for her because they do such a good
job at setting up how she and her
husband are so grateful to be parents
because they were given this chance and
so once it becomes apparent that
problems are happening the breakdown of
that family was what made this movie
work so well for me yeah there's some
cool really fucked up deaths and you
know like a twist of the superhero
formula but that to me was sort of like
the icing on the cake at the core of
this movie what made it work for me were
two parents grateful to have a child
slowly realizing that it's a giant
mistake and having to come to terms with
that I love that part of the movie and
they nailed it also a major plus with
bright burn is that it looks way more
expensive than it was when my friends
and I left the theater we were like what
do you think that was shot for maybe
like 20 million we looked on IMDB and
it's listed as a 7 million dollar budget
so the stuff they were able to pull off
I'm very impressed with it seems like
they had a tight-knit crew of people who
are willing to work extra hard on this
movie and that could come from James
Gunn being the producer because one of
the reasons that slither is behind me
right now is because he directed that
film it's a really fun horror film check
it out but Elizabeth Banks is also in
that movie and it was inspiring purely
from a production standpoint to see how
much they were able to do with that
smaller budget that's something that I
am trying to learn a lot about right now
about how to stretch a budget to its
limits and this is a good example of
that still there are some elements of
the movie that frustrated me and it's a
different type of frustration when I see
a film like this I'm pulling for it I'm
kind of rooting for it and there are
things that I wish could have been
better because
I'm hoping that they do a great job with
this movie and so as I watch the film
I'm seeing missed opportunities which is
frustrating but it's not maddening like
wow they really fuck that up it's more
like oh what if you had just done this
thing differently here that would have
really helped your film for instance the
opening scene of the film is the ship
crash-landing in the farm and so you
know right off the bat okay the kids an
alien now if this were say a spec script
which if you don't know what a spec
script is it's an unsolicited script
someone who's a writer they write a
script and they're hoping to get it made
I doubt this was a spec script because
the people who wrote it are related to
James Gunn and that's instantly like an
amazing connection to get your film
through a lot more doors than if you
were just an average Joe disclaimer
though I don't know the full history of
the bright burn script but I'm assuming
that more than likely they wrote it with
the goal of getting it made from the
very beginning if this were a spec
script though what aspect writer wants
to do is they want to impress you
hardcore because they are pulling out
all the stops to make their script as
best as they can possibly make it so
they can get people's attention in that
case I would not have opened this movie
with the spaceship crashing because you
instantly give away that secret from the
very beginning I would have had the
movie play the way it does but without
that opening scene because you got this
kid drawn to the barn something in the
barn is calling him he's trying to open
the door there's this glow behind the
barn and you're wondering what the hell
is back there holy shit he's eating his
breakfast and he just broke the fork off
in his mouth what the fuck is going on
in this movie like there's so much they
could do if they didn't give away right
from the beginning the kids an alien and
I feel like if this were a spec script
they could have explored that a lot more
and it would have been sort of like a
mid film twist that could have brought
something really interesting the table
but instead we know right off the bat
kids nail Ian so it kind of takes away
the mystery but I would say my biggest
issue with the movie is that it does
feel rushed a lot happens in a span of
about 91 minutes it's very quick and a
lot of development and a lot of
emotional changing has to occur in a
short span of time while also setting up
a plot and trying to explain a backstory
about where this
it is from or what exactly is
controlling him which is also an issue
you're not entirely sure what the kid's
motivation is because there's times in
the movie where he expresses that he
wants to be good but you don't really
get a chance to see him attempting to be
good there's just many scenes in which
he does horrific things but you don't
really see a struggle within him between
good and evil it seems like one day he
just wakes up and something's in the
barn and all of a sudden he's like
called to be evil so I think of the
rules of whatever's going on within this
kid and the thing in the barn and
whatever his goals are we're just a
little more clear the film could have
been better and if they didn't
necessarily give away the secret in the
opening scene they could have played
with the audience a lot more and done
things to toy with our expectations but
I think overall this is an enjoyable
horror movie and it is definitely a
horror movie because once the kid is
active so to speak it kind of becomes a
slasher film which I liked I'm gonna
give bright burn be guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews very soon and as always
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]